während die meisten menschen zurzeit
kaum ihren wohnort verlassen können
reist eine privilegierte exklusive
touristengruppe putzmunter und völlig
unbehindert um die welt isas co2 viren
samt ihrer buckligen verwandtschaft
namens mutationen verlassen flugzeug
oder schiff wo und wie es ihnen gefällt
und verbreiten unter den einheimischen
angst und schrecken
deutschland ist als reiseziel bislang
glimpflich davon gekommen
die welt kämpft gegen korona wie gehen
andere länder vor
jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste so wächst hier im studio
bei der sowohl ist bei uns sie schreiben
für zeit online betreiben einen podcast
mit dem titel rise entscheiden das weist
auf ihre vietnamesischer herkunft hin es
ist die vietnamesische sicht auf
deutschland zu vielen themen wendelin
von bredow ist bei uns sie sind aus dem
berliner büro der londoner
wirtschaftszeitung sie ökonomisch und
zugeschaltet meine kolleginnen zunächst
aus dem zdf studio in johannesburg
sandra eis zuständig für die
berichterstattung des zdf aus dem
südlichen afrika und natalia bachmayer
aus dem ard-studio in madrid auch
zuständig nicht nur für spanien sondern
auch für portugal und damit sind wir
schon bei dem stichwort frau bachmeier
spanien und portugal ihre berichts
gebiete sind große problemgebiete in
großer bedrängnis was corona angeht die
inzidenz sind in spanien 455 heute und
portugal weltspitze mit 700 incidents
die bundeswehr jetzt da angekommen mit
acht intensivbetten 50 beatmungsgeräten
und 150 infusions anlagen
man kann sich kaum vorstellen dass das
ausreicht wie ist denn gerade in
portugal im moment die situation
angespannt wäre sehr vorsichtig
ausgedrückt die situation ist
katastrophal
gerade auf den intensivstationen der
öffentlichen krankenhäuser arbeiten die
leute am limit ich habe gerade gestern
noch mit dem chef der intensivstation
des größten krankenhauses in portugal
gesprochen in lissabon
der sagte mir die arbeitsstunden werden
im moment verdoppelt in manchen wochen
im januar waren sie sogar verdreifacht
also man kann wirklich sagen die liegt
die leute sind eigentlich schon über das
limit hinaus sie geben ihr bestes aber
[Musik]
sie haben gerade angesprochen die
bundeswehr ist gekommen anlässlich
dieser anfrage an deutschland ob man
nicht helfen könne wurde diskutiert ob
nicht jetzt vielleicht die privaten
krankenhäuser auch mal in die pflicht
genommen werden könnten denn da war die
lage bis vor kurzem noch sehr sehr
entspannt da scheint sich nah an
einigung anzudeuten aber die wut gerade
in den öffentlichen krankenhäuser unter
den beschäftigten war groß dass die sich
bisher so gar nicht beteiligt hatten
in südafrika gab es ja im vergangenen
frühjahr einen ganz harten lockdown die
leute die menschen wurden regelrecht
eingesperrt in ihre wohnungen bewacht
von der polizei es gab ein absolutes
alkoholverbot im ganzen land jetzt
bietet südafrika einen ganz hässlichen
exportartikel nämlich eine virus
mutation die sich auch schon über die
halbe welt verbreitet hat was macht das
eigentlich mit der politischen der
wirtschaftlichen der sozial und der
gesundheitlichen situation in südafrika
also man muss sagen dass wir eigentlich
zwei sehr verschiedene strategien
gesehen haben wie die regierung auf die
situation reagiert hat wir haben eben
wie sie schon sagten im märz am 27 märz
diesen sehr harten lockdown gehabt wir
haben viel polizeigewalt auch gesehen
und wir haben gesehen dass in der folge
dessen letzten endes die wirtschaft
komplett zusammengebrochen ist also es
hat millionen menschen den jobs also
ihre jobs verloren und es war eine
absolute katastrophe
und das land hat auch gemerkt dass es
sich das eigentlich gar nicht leisten
kann dass die jetzt wo die zahlen und um
den jahreswechsel wieder massiv in die
höhe gestiegen sind wir hatten um die
20.000 infektionen täglich zeitweise da
hat man sich überlegt okay wir müssen
irgendwie was machen aber wir können
nicht wieder die ganze wirtschaft
komplett runter fahren weil der schaden
am ende möglicherweise noch größer ist
also wir haben auch eine hungerkrise
gehabt nach dem ersten lockt oder durch
den ersten lockdown und das wollte man
auf jeden fall vermeiden was wir dieses
mal gesehen haben ist dass man sozusagen
versucht hat das leben dort
einzuschränken wo quasi abstands regeln
häufig missachtet werden das heißt ende
dezember hat die regierung einen
schärferen lockdown wieder verhängt aber
sie hat geschäfte offen gelassen sie hat
restaurants offen gelassen parks und
strände geschlossen umgekehrt mussten
die restaurants um 8 uhr schon schließen
und durften auch jetzt wieder keinen
alkohol ausschenken und es dürfte auch
keiner verkauft werden aber das hat sehr
gut funktioniert also die zahlen sind
drastisch zurückgegangen
wir hatten zeitweise um die 2000 täglich
gestern war's dann 4000 also stand
gestern man etwas über 4000 und insofern
hat diese strategie ganz funktionieren
dann aber ganz gut funktioniert aber
einen richtig harten locker und kann
sich das land eigentlich gar nicht lasst
euch sagen dass südafrika anders als in
deutschland gerade sommer herrscht was
die sache natürlich weiter erschwert von
bredow das vereinigte königreich steht
ja auch nicht besonders daher incidents
heute glaube ich 236 deutschland sind 87
im moment aber das land ist seit wochen
unverdrossen
was sind denn trotz dieser tatsache dass
da jetzt richtig geimpft wird die
ursache für die doch recht hohe
incidents für ein europäisches also gut
portugal akteure aber zumindestens für
großbritannien recht hohe intelligenz
also der hauptgrund dass die inzidenz
immer noch so hoch sind ist diese
mutation nicht die wird ja auch mal die
britische variante genannt und die ist
eben sehr viel ansteckender der boris
johnson der premierminister hat sogar
auch mal gesagt sie wäre tödlicher das
wurde dann von wissenschaftlern
widersprochen
aber auf jeden fall ist die ansteckender
und natürlich darum durch auch im
endeffekt ehrlicher war einfach mehr
leute auch schwer erkranken
aber der grund also für die doch noch
sehr hohen zahlen obwohl ja schon neun
millionen menschen geimpft sind das ist
viel viel höher als in allen anderen
europäischen ländern ist eben diese
diese sehr viele sich rapide
ausbreitende variante wo jetzt haben wir
die ganzen probleme und das negative
beleuchtet es gibt auch lichtblicke auf
der welt was corona angeht zum beispiel
eine ganze reihe von ländern in asien da
klingt das wort locker und wie ein
ferner donnerhall aus dem letzten
frühjahr da gibt es nämlich schon längst
keinen mehr
im prinzip geht das leben fast ohne
einschränkungen ganz normal weiter auch
was die zusammenkunft der menschen an
gehen die restaurants sind geöffnet die
konzerthallen
woran liegt das eigentlich ist in
manchen asiatischen ländern
was wir schon immer vermutet haben sind
da die themen disziplin und gemeinsinn
einfach weiterentwickelt ich denke dass
der kulturelle faktoren auch mit 1
spielt aber hauptsächlich sind diese
länder einfach sehr krisenerprobten das
epidemien angeht also es gab 2002 3 zum
beispiel hunde und auch 2005 sendern die
saßen die meeres epidemien jeweils um
die einzelne länder hatten daraus
gelernt sie hatten auch diese epidemie
nicht gut im griff muss man sagen sie
haben auch teilweise ihre regierungen
abgewählt deswegen in südkorea zum
beispiel und jetzt waren sie sehr darum
bemüht keine fehler
jetzt machen die
infektionsschutzgesetzes lagen schon
bereit es gab viele andere politische
maßnahmen masken wurden schon fertig
produziert das heißt die npd musste nur
noch kommen und die leute waren darauf
gefasst und konnten sofort reagieren das
heißt es für das virus war gab es da
keine ausbildungsmöglichkeiten erst gar
nicht um sich gegriffen und es war ja
gab eben die entsprechenden maßnahmen
jetzt ist das ein beispiel wie man es
vielleicht hier möglicherweise auch
machen könnte da werden wir gleich noch
darüber wie man es nicht machen sollte
dafür haben wir auch ein beispiel das
ist portugal natalia bachmayer
im vergangenen jahr war das land ja ein
musterknabe unter den europäischen
staaten die haben eine ganz niedrige
incidents auch ganz wenige
neuinfektionen auch eine niedrige
todeszahl das hat sich jetzt völlig
umgedreht allein im januar sind alles
ist eine fünfstellige zahl von menschen
gestorben an dem salzhof 2 virus woran
lag das dass portugal sowie sich in
schlechte gekehrt hat ich finde es
hochinteressant was frau buch gerade
gesagt hat also sie hat ja gesagt die
asien ist man pandemie erprobt bei uns
noch nicht so und man muss sagen die
portugiesen sind wirklich salopp gesagt
kalt erwischt worden von dem was da
passiert ist eine frau die auf der
straße interviewt wurde hat gesagt wir
haben immer noch nicht kapiert dass wir
vom corona musterland europas oder von
einem der korona musterländer zu einem
problem land geworden sind und ich
glaube portugals problem war jetzt das
alles so wahnsinnig schnell passiert ist
im grunde kann man sagen also im januar
ging die kurve also wirklich so fast
vertikal nach oben
dass das der feiertags effekt war die
leute sind in die regionen rausgefahren
aus den ballungsräumen was halt speziell
dazu kam war das da sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich die englische variante
des virus die englische mutation schon
mit macht in den ballungsräumen
unterwegs war und dass die auf diese art
und weise im ganzen land verteilt wurde
das heißt es ging alles viel viel zu
schnell in portugal um noch rechtzeitig
reagieren zu können und die generell
wenn man so mit den leuten redet die
sagt wir haben uns in sicherheit gewiegt
wir dachten wir haben das jetzt
ausgeschwitzt und dem war mitnichten so
die englischen touristen sind ja sogar
besonders häufig vertreten aber diese
art von tourismus will man
wahrscheinlich da nicht haben mit dem
virus auch im vereinigten königreich
weil man ja relativ leichtsinnig vor
allen dingen die regierung war
offensichtlich leichtsinnig den ball
johnson hat ja letztes jahr im
frühsommer das eigentlich so ein
bisschen auf die leichte schulter
genommen hat ein bisschen geändert dem
verhalten seines damaligen freundes
donald trump ist das nicht auch deswegen
so leichtsinnig gewesen weil das
britische gesundheitssystem ja
gefürchtet ist für seine ineffizienz und
seine verletzlichkeit dass man da
einfach drüber weg gegangen ist was das
für konsequenzen haben könnte ja absolut
also das einzige weiße preischancen
richtig gemacht hat oder gut gemacht hat
ist jetzt schon die das impfen und die
beschaffung des impfstoffes das haben
die schnell und effizient und eigentlich
vorbildlich gemacht aber alles andere
war eine ziemliche katastrophe hat es
auf eine sehr leichte schulter genommen
und hat das wurde ja selber sogar und
zwar schwer kann es ist ja ziemlich
schwer an ronal krank und es war auch
dann so eine hott strategie es wurde es
war überhaupt keine klare linie also und
es war sehr sehr lange und die zahlen
sind wenn man sich anschaut
großbritannien hat doppelt so viele
todesfälle wie deutschland mit aber sehr
viel wenigen einwohnern also es ist es
die haben sehr viele todesopfer zu
beklagen und das er hätte es war
teilweise total überlastet
das gesundheitssystem das britische
gesundheitssystem und man sah also in
großbritannien ähnliche bilder wie jetzt
in portugal wo die ambulanzen sich vor
den krankenhäusern in der schlange
standen und die patienten in den
ambulanzen behandelt wurden weil es
überhaupt gar keine betten mehr gab und
die waren wirklich am anschlag hat sich
jetzt etwas entspannt aber es ist immer
noch natürlich drücken auch ein bisschen
weniger aufgeregt als vielleicht
hierzulande die etwas cooler nehmen und
damit vielleicht aber auch gefahren
nicht so ernst nehmen denn sie wirklich
da sind das ist sicher auch das
britische fleck mal ein bisschen also es
waren eben auch sehr lange zeit das
haben meine freunde und familie auch in
london erzielt dass die die regeln die
waren ja nie
manu chelsea waren es wurde immer mehr
so vorgeschlagen was man machen soll und
die leute haben sich daneben auch
wirklich nicht wirklich daran gehalten
also zum beispiel im öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln sehr lange hatten dann
fast niemand eine einen mundschutz
getragen wenn ich das hat sich jetzt ein
bisschen geändert aber das war eben
lange nicht gefallen das war da in
deutschland in vielen europäischen
ländern doch ganz anders ist südafrika
ist hier hat ja fast die hälfte aller
bekannten infektionen aus dem
afrikanischen kontinent zu verzeichnen
jetzt wissen wir nicht wie in anderen
ländern das registriert wird diese
statistik ist vielleicht auch mit
vorsicht zu genießen trotzdem das land
ist richtig gestorben
jetzt muss man ja sagen für afrikanische
verhältnisse südafrika wer die
wohlhabend die menschen können dort
reißt es ist auch ein wichtiges ziel für
ausländische touristen erklärt dass auch
ein bisschen diese hohe zahl das was
auch europa oder nordamerika auszeichnet
und teile von asien diese hohen
mobilität dass die das natürlich alles
gefördert hat die ausbreitung eben auch
im südlichen afrika
also ich denke insofern auf alle fälle
als dass es ja touristen waren
wesentlichen aus dem europäischen raum
die das virus überhaupt erst nach
südafrika gebracht haben und man hat
hier ja auch viele reisebeschränkungen
gehabt dass es war zeitweise verboten
sich von einer provinz in die andere
provinz innerhalb von südafrika zu
bewegen
einfach weil man versucht hat die ganze
ausbreitung ein bisschen einzudämmen
wir haben aber eben auch viele leute die
aus nachbarländern kommen aus simbabwe
beispielsweise oder malawi und die eben
in südafrika arbeiten und da sind die
grenzen auch nicht unbedingt immer mal
so richtig gut kontrolliert worden
da hat man dann irgendwann auch gesagt
wir müssen das wirklich zu machen damit
wir die verbreitung einigermaßen
eindämmen können also die mobilität
spielt sicher nicht eine große rolle
aber ich glaube dass die größte rolle im
moment tatsächlich die neue variante
gespielt hat also die hat richtig für
einen massiven anstieg der
infektionszahlen gesorgt
diese neue variante sorgte dafür dass
man eigentlich keine prognose geben kann
wie es jetzt aber in südafrika weiter
geht wann die zahlen runter gehen wann
man das möglicherweise im griff hat das
impfen auch in südafrika reden wer
gleich noch
das ist ja ein riesenproblem eigentlich
für das land das ja gerade auch vom
tourismus lebt dass sie ein sehr
beliebtes reiseziel ist das ja
eigentlich auf absehbare zeit sequenzen
für touristen gar nicht öffnen kann
wir haben jetzt gerade in einem
wildreservat die waren in man dicke game
reserve haben dort auf einer lodge
gedreht der eigentümer hat uns gesagt 95
prozent meiner gäste die kommen aus
übersee aus europa kanada usa und die
gäste fehlen jetzt natürlich da waren
gerade mal zwei touristen da das waren
südafrikaner die in pretoria lebten etwa
viereinhalb stunden von den park
entfernt aber ansonsten steht die lodge
quasi leer und das ist ein problem nicht
nur für diese einzelne lodz wo das den
betreiber trifft natürlich an sondern
das ist ein problem für die ganze region
denn diese lodges quasi exemplare steht
die für alle anderen lodges in allen
anderen parks genauso die menschen die
auf diesen gottes arbeiten
die kommen aus den dörfern die rund um
die parks liegen das sind ranger das
sind kellner das sind zimmermädchen und
von dem gehalt was die verdienen
ernähren die eine ganze familie da
hängen oft bis zu zehn personen dran
und in dem moment wo natürlich die lodge
nicht mehr läuft verdient also verlieren
die entweder ganz ihren job oder aber
sie werden nur noch sporadisch
eingesetzt und verdienen dann eben
weniger und das ist ein riesenproblem
das heißt das sorgt für eine ganz große
armut und teilweise auch hungerkrise in
der region um diese parks herum wo in
deutschland gibt es im zusammenhang mit
krone auch eine diskussion mit dem label
datenschutz contra gesundheitsschutz
da sind ganz heißes eisen kann der
eigene frühlingssonne von machen
das ist ja in asiatische länder kein
unversöhnlicher gegensatz in taiwan zum
beispiel hat er sogar sehr gut
funktioniert und ist der datenschutz ja
trotzdem eingehalten worden weil diese
app die die quarantäne überwacht hat ja
dann also diese daten dann gelöscht
worden sind nach beendigung der
kerntechnik können sie da kurz schildern
was da passiert ist und warum es in
taiwan so gut geklappt hat mit dem
ergebnis dass es da ja kaum noch corona
gibt in taiwan haben sich einfach auf
einem transparenten datenschutz geeinigt
also während man hier in deutschland
davor angst hat überhaupt seine daten
irgendwo hin zu geben und zwar überall
hin
dann gibt es ja auch schon zu verlieren
aber da aber für so was geht es dann
nicht mehr
und dort war so okay wir wissen genau
welche daten
wie abgeben und für welchen begrenzten
zeitraum und danach werden sie ganz
sicher gelöscht das geht auch nicht mehr
ab sondern tatsächlich über die
sim-karte mit auch angerufen und nach
diesen begrenzten zeitraum ist man
einfach sicher dass sie da nicht
einbehalten werden also es ist zum
beispiel auch möglich für den zeit sich
für den zeitraum eine andere sim-karte
zu besorgen wenn ich sage ich werde
jetzt zwei wochen überwacht weil ich in
quarantäne sein muss ist gilt nur für
quarantäne pflichtigen dann kauf ich mir
neue sim-karte nach schmeiße ich sie weg
und dann weiß ich auch sich das dann
niemand mehr darauf zugriff hat und das
ist ein datenschutz verständnis dass
hier eigentlich auch vereinbar wäre also
wirklich komplette transparenz was dann
mit den daten passiert und die daten
löschen
sie lebe schon lange hier warum glauben
sie ist das in deutschland so schwierig
ist das einfach nur eine fixe idee ist
das eine sagt es mal etwas hat sich eine
ideologische borniertheit dass man dazu
wenig flexibel ist oder sagt also
eigentlich ist der datenschutz wichtiger
als meine gesundheit ist es eine
seltsame einstellung nein ich glaube die
deutschen haben sehr gute gründe extrem
auf den datenschutz zu achten mann hat
im zweiten weltkrieg sehr negative
erfahrungen gemacht mit datenerfassungen
aufgrund derer dann wieder menschen
verfolgt wurden und auch getötet wurden
es gibt sehr gute historische gründe
aber es gibt eben auch gute modernen
kontrollmechanismen die man anwenden
kann und keine flexibilität dafür zu
zeigen angesichts einer so extrem
ernsten lage ist mir persönlich auch
nicht so verständlich ich denke halt der
die letzte sehr große krise mit dem
zweiten weltkrieg ist einfach eine weile
her und in asiatischen ländern ist es
komplett anders die haben ihre letzten
kriege die sind viel jünger noch und
auch die zeiten danach es gab viele
politische umbrüche viele
systemänderungen und da ist man glaube
ich auch anders flexibel im kopf einfach
dann denkt man sich ok bedrohung wir
müssen jetzt so vorlegen was machen wir
müssen handeln es kommt auf
schnelligkeit an
dieses denken ist hier nicht mehr so
präsent wir leben einfach schon ziemlich
lange in wohlstand das heißt die
schmerzgrenze ist noch nicht erreicht
man sich wirklich dann überlebt das
überlegt dass man die pandemie wirklich
nur mit solchen maßnahmen noch bekämpfen
kann
ich glaube es gibt ja auch einfach so
eine gewisse naivität man auch immer
dieses gerede von wir müssen mit diesem
virus leben und asiatischen länder haben
die erfahrung gemacht
wir müssen nicht mit einem los leben wir
sind modern wir haben so etwas wie
wissenschaftlich haben so was die
politik und ein verhältnis von staat und
gesellschaft die sich gegenseitig
kontrollieren können und etwas machen
können so und diese handlungsmacht und
handlungsfähigkeit das ist
der ist noch nicht in so vielen köpfen
hier jetzt es gibt es ja aber natürlich
muss man nicht will niemand mit dem
virus leben und ob jetzt angela merkel
boris johnson oder zweiten alle klammern
sich an einen an eine hoffnung nämlich
namens impfen das wird dann alles besser
werden
dann müssen wir jetzt nochmal unsere
einzelnen positionen hier ja wie soll
ich sagen abklappern natalia bachmayer
impfen in spanien und portugal spanien
ist ja auch nicht besonders gut dran
es geht ja auch darum dass die impfdosen
moment noch sehr ungleich verteilt sind
das liegt auch daran dass ist ja im
moment noch relativ wenig impfstoff gibt
ihr die herstellung hat ja gerade
begonnen die sitzt da auf der iberischen
halbinsel aus in deutschland ist das ja
ein wichtiges thema falsche
impfstrategie zu wenig bestellt worden
falsch informiert man fühlt sich auch
von den impfstoffherstellern
hintergangen
wie ist die inflation im moment in
spanien und in portugal die ist der
deutschen nicht ganz unähnlich würde ich
sagen mit allen vor und nachteilen
tatsächlich ist man sich dessen auch
sehr bewusst hier dass man da natürlich
den europäischen regularien unterworfen
ist bzw von europa abhängig ist wie das
organisiert wurde
ich sag mal so das wird hier relativ
pragmatisch gesehen und auch in portugal
gibt es da jetzt keine großen
beschwerden allerdings der berühmte
bürgermeister ist im moment der der
bekannteste bürger spaniens hier zum
beispiel wird immer gesagt na ja also
wenn man wenn man entsprechend verletzt
ist usw
dann scheint man sich doch die impfung
holen zu können bevor man eigentlich
der der skalierung nach dran wäre
und darüber wird sich dann gemütlich hin
und wieder mal aufgeregt im großen und
ganzen wird es aber ganz entspannt
angegangen und und die leute sind auch
sehr sehr duldsam obwohl sie natürlich
schon sehen dass es stockt besonders
heiß wie ist das in südafrika auf dem
papier sind da ja ich glaube es sind
neulich sogar schon die erste million
impfdosen angekommen der staatspräsident
hat die persönlich in empfang genommen
auf dem flughafen kann südafrika mit
genügend impfdosen in nächster zeit
rechnen dass auch so etwas sieht
absehbarer zeit wie herdenimmunität
entstehen kann
naja das ist die frage also in
absehbarer zeit in den nächsten monaten
sicherlich nicht wir haben jetzt am
montag wie sie schon sagten die erste
million dosen impfstoff bekommen die es
auch mit großem brimborium in empfang
genommen worden vielleicht auch weil man
ein bisschen kassieren wollte dass die
regierung eigentlich ein bisschen
geschlafen hat also sehr hätte viel
frühzeitiger schon in verhandlungen
treten müssen also mit den
impfstoffherstellern das land hat sich
jetzt insgesamt rund 50 millionen dosen
impfstoff gesichert wenn man davon
ausgeht dass man zwei dosen pro person
braucht dann würde das für 25 millionen
menschen reichen wir haben hier
geschätzt etwa 58 millionen menschen die
wissenschaftler hier gehen davon aus
dass man für eine herdenimmunität 67
prozent der bevölkerung impfen muss
dafür würde das allein von der menge her
im moment noch nicht reichen so richtig
gut aus geboren ist der plan zum impfen
im moment auch noch nicht also da gibt
es einige stellschrauben wo noch
gearbeitet werden muss interessant ist
aber auch dass der letzten umfrage
zufolge nur 53 prozent der bevölkerung
überhaupt bereit sind sich impfen zu
lassen
und was auch ein problem ist dass die
bevölkerung hier natürlich auch sehr
viel jünger ist als beispielsweise in
deutschland und es gibt ja auch
impfstoffe die sind für unter 16 jährige
gar nicht zugelassen also von daher ist
das thema werden immobilien also
herdenimmunität glaube ich noch ein
bisschen schwierig hier und nicht so
richtig schnell erreichbar
jetzt gehört ja zu jedem berichts gebiet
ich habe am anfang gesagt eben nicht nur
südafrika soll das gesamte südliche
afrika besteht ja aus einer ganzen reihe
von staaten wie zum teil ja anders
wirtschaftlich sozial auch politische
aufgestellt sind als südafrika wie sieht
es da aus
vom nachbarland simbabwe hat man ja
gehört 90 ihrer beamten nach hause
geschickt um diese infektionskette zu
durchbrechen mit dem ergebnis dass die
behörden nicht mehr arbeiten was für ein
land ja eine katastrophe ist dass man
sich mal in jedem land vorstellen und
ich nehme an dass keine ein laptop zum
zweiten zuhause arbeiten zu können aus
dem klassischen home office wie sieht es
in den anderen staaten rund um südafrika
aus das ist halt von land zu land sehr
unterschiedlich aber ich glaube was
grundsätzlich das problem ist dass viele
länder überhaupt in afrika also jetzt
nicht nur im südlichen afrika sondern
auch in west- und ostafrika sich die
impfstoffe in großem stil gar nicht
leisten können und deren einzige chance
tatsächlich impfstoffe zu bekommen ist
die initiative kovacs unter dem dach der
whu das sind ja 190 staaten die sich da
zusammen geschlossen haben
und das ziel ist es bis ende dieses
jahres zumindest 20 prozent der
bevölkerung auch in den ärmsten ländern
zu impfen aber wie das tatsächlich
wirklich umgesetzt werden soll es noch
völlig fragt fraglich weil wir haben
einerseits gibt es also fehlen
milliarden sozusagen um auch diese 20
prozent die impfdosen zu finanzieren und
das andere problem ist die infrastruktur
sind es gibt einfach also diese
impfstoffe die bei -20 oder minus 70
grad gekühlt werden müssen
die sind einfach in vielen teilen
afrikas gerade in ländlichen regionen
nicht wirklich lieferbar und auch also
man kann die kühlung nicht sicherstellen
und das ist einfach ein riesengroßes
problem
das gilt aber für andere länder in
lateinamerika auch in teilen von asien
oder ozeanien gleichermaßen müssen diese
länder dann die gerade diese kühlkette
nicht sicherstellen können damit dann
auch rechnen dass sie eben noch lange
nicht bedacht werden selbst wenn
impfdosen da wären oder spendern die
diese impfdosen in diese länder schicken
könnten
geht die frage jetzt an mich ja ja dass
man sich genau nein ich habe jetzt es
gibt auch andere länder nicht nur in
afrika sondern auch in lateinamerika und
asien wo er diese kühlketten auch nicht
vorhanden sind das heißt diese länder
müssen ja da es ja viel konkurrenz auch
um einen relativ leicht handelbaren
impfstoff gibt ja dann noch sehr lange
warten bis sie überhaupt etwas bekommen
selbst wenn es genügend impfstoff auf
dem markt gibt ja ich denke schon ich
glaube das ist das große problem also
wir haben also der impfstoff der sich
für afrika auch laut whu eben am ehesten
eignen würde wäre dann astrazeneca
einfach weil der bei
kühlschranktemperatur transportiert und
gelagert werden kann
allerdings hat astrazeneca den ersten
studien zufolge offenbar auch nur eine
wirksamkeit von 49 prozent gegenüber der
neuen südafrikanischen variante
und die setzt im moment zumindest im
südlichen afrika einigen staaten zu und
insofern ist die frage wie viel das dann
auch tatsächlich hilft andererseits muss
man sagen naja 50 prozent weniger kranke
50 prozent weniger belastung in den
krankenhäusern kann vielen menschen
wieder das leben retten da wo die
systeme überlastet sind
das haben wir hier auch gesehen dass die
systeme rund um den jahreswechsel so
massiv überlastet waren
die krankenhäuser so überlastet waren
das einfach menschen zu spät hilfe
bekommen haben und das sind tote gewesen
die nicht hätten sein müssen wenn die
nötigen ressourcen da gewesen wäre also
die logistik hakt und die wirksamkeit
ist auch noch schlecht entwickelt jetzt
gibt es ja von der whu der
weltgesundheitsorganisation den
vorschlag dass die patente die die
meistens in westlichen staaten sitzenden
impfstoffhersteller pharmakonzerne
entwickelt haben freigegeben werden
können um eben mehr impfstoff
herzustellen und auch die richtigen
überall alle welt zu schicken da haben
aber schon die europäische union das
vereinigte königreich die usa an schweiz
gesagt machen wir nicht lässt sich diese
position durch halten da geht es
natürlich vor allen dingen um
wirtschaftliche fragen um gewinne und
profite auch um anteile an dem welt im
stoffmarkt das wäre ja sozusagen eine
ganz soziale haltung
glauben sie dass sich die durchsetzen
kann oder dass eine situation entsteht
dass die impfstoffhersteller in dieser
frage nachgeben müssen
das kommt jetzt auf den verlauf an also
wenn es wenn die impfstoffhersteller es
schaffen die pharmaunternehmen wirklich
massiv die produktion zu steigern und
wirklich die impfstoffe die benötigt
werden zu liefern und da gab es ja jetzt
schon ein hacker mit astrazeneca der so
ein bisschen falls gelöst wurde dann
glaube ich werden die fahrer in also
wenn sie das schaffen dann dann dann
können sie bei diesem standpunkt bleiben
und ihre wirtschaftlichen interessen
fall aber wenn die werden dies weiter so
aus dem ruder läuft wie das ja durch
diese varianten sein könnte dann glaube
ich kann müssten die patente freigegeben
werden aber das ist noch das ist ja noch
nie wirklich so da gewesen
dann gibt es da überhaupt die auch die
möglichkeit dann in möglichst oder in
sehr viel mehr ländern als bisher diese
diese impfstoffe herzustellen das ist ja
auch eine andere frage
es müssen ja nicht nur die patente
freigegeben werden das müssen ja auch
produktionsanlagen dann da sein die in
viel größerem maße noch impfstoffe
herstellen
die haben in deutschland auch das
problem das vorgestern hier ein
vertreter der pharmaindustrie gesagt hat
oder der impfstoffhersteller
wir brauchen sechs bis sieben monate bis
wir selbst in deutschland in einem gut
ausgestatteten land eine entsprechende
fabrik praktische produktionsfähig
machen ist denn das dann auch wirklich
so einfach ist dass die sozusagen der
die lösung die patente antwort
freizugeben und der rest ergibt sich
nein so einfach ist das nicht haben wir
schon gesehen in der produktion und der
logistik gibt es ganz große problem nach
probleme die man nicht vorhersehen
könnte und besonders so schnell geht das
sieht man auch nicht also insofern aber
wenn wir denn wenn das das wird die eben
da alles länger dauern als wir denken
falls sich diese varianten ausbreiten
dann müsste man eben wirklich versuchen
die produktionsweisen ausbreiten und in
so vielen ländern wie möglich einfach
alles daran setzen so viel von diesen
stoffen wie möglich zu produzieren
und da müssen alle lösungen jedenfalls
zur diskussion stehen hilfsbereit zu
sein das kommt ja immer gut an in der
welt in china zum beispiel
hat man sich jetzt überlegt im wasser
teils gerade angesprochen hat mit diesem
kodex möglichst viele impfdosen eben in
entwicklungsländer zu schicken
zehn millionen soll jetzt unmittelbar
zur verfügung gestellt werden
china entwickelt der eigene impfstoffe
die angeblich auch schneller und
billiger herzustellen sind als die im
westen dass china auch ausnutzen auch in
geo strategischer hinsicht zu sagen also
wir stellen das nicht nur hier sondern
wir ließen das in große mengen auch an
die länder die das nötig haben hier aus
ist es jetzt gerade so ein sehr
politisiert das wort aber china hat
einfach erscheint die kapazitäten
entwickelt schnell ein impfstoff zu
liefern
und man muss schon sagen dass in dieser
gesamten corona pandemie china einfach
einen geopolitischen vorteil errungen
hat sie sind einfach sehr erfolgreich
vorgegangen sie konnten auch
wirtschaftliche schäden
so wie wir hier haben zum beispiel
stärker ausbremsen und auch einfach rein
propaganda mäßig ist natürlich eine ganz
andere rede da von dem schwachen westen
das jetzt infiziertes und das ist nicht
so richtig auf die reihe kriegt und wir
hier im starken china und da spielt
natürlich der eigene impfstoff auch mit
rein was ich noch interessant finde es
ist nicht nur china das den eigenen
impfstoff entwickelt sondern tatsächlich
ist wird dann auch mit vier eigenen
kandidaten dabei am ehesten
schwellenland das ist eigentlich nie
wissenschaftlich groß aufgefallen
aber ich denke dass es eben auch länder
gibt wenn sie ressourcen haben sie nicht
komplett abhängig sein wollen von
westlichen industrienationen dass sie
irgendwann mal irgendwas abbekommen dh
sie sind auch in dem kovacs programmen
wo wir sie 2022 mit ersten impfstoffen
rechnen
bis dahin werden sie aber versuchen eine
politische antwort auf die man ii mi zu
finden weil es nicht mehr gehen wird und
ihre eigene entwicklung sind sie
tatsächlich auch optimistisch ab dem
nächsten jahr vielleicht mit dem eigenen
flugzeug
es gibt jetzt diese neue freihandelszone
die ja gerade sich zum ziel gesetzt hat
in ostasien und südostasien eben eigene
auch industrielle standards zu
entwickeln eben um sich vom westen
unabhängiger zu machen das sind also
sozusagen jetzt hören sie weiß ich wie
wirksam die einzelne impfstoffe sind die
da entwickelt werden so eine art eaton
champions mit denen man im moment gar
nicht rechnet und die möglicherweise das
im problem lösen könnten
ich glaube da muss man sehr vorsichtig
sein weil bis jetzt wurden die im stoff
entwicklungen nicht so transparent
gehandhabt wir wissen nicht viel über
ihre wirksamkeit wissen auch nicht genau
nicht sehr viel über die klinischen
studien in den verschiedenen testphasen
zum beispiel das heißt wir können nur
sehen dass dieser länder selbst
anscheinend optimistisch sind und
einfach schon mal anfangen zu impfen
letzten endes müssen wir aber
langfristig gucken ob es überhaupt so
viel wirkt wie die zum beispiel sagen es
kann sein dass ich das als hätten jam er
weiß und das viele andere länder danach
kaufen werden um die dann dadurch den
wahnsinnigen wechsel wettbewerbsvorteil
haben moment ist aber auch noch nicht so
also die reicheren industriestaaten in
asien südkorea zum beispiel singapur
japan
die setzen auch eigentlich eher auf
astrazeneca und sonntag so bachmann
was in spanien und portugal jetzt gerade
vor sich geht das ist ja sehr
besorgniserregend was brauchen denn
spanien aber besonders portugal
eigentlich in nächster zeit noch neben
dieser bundeswehr hilfe muss noch sehr
viel mehr passieren um in portugal diese
diesen notstand in den griff zu kriegen
ich glaube spanien und österreich haben
sich bereit erklärt schwer erkrankte
cupid 19 patienten aus portugal aus zu
fliegen um das dortige gesundheitssystem
zu entlasten aber irgendwie wirkt das
dass man bei den zahlen die da zu
befürchten sind das auch nicht ausreicht
was muss denn noch passieren muss da
vielleicht eine konzertierte aktion der
gesamten europäischen union her
möglicherweise ich hatte ja am anfang
unserer gesprächsrunde schon angedeutet
es ist vor allen dingen so also portugal
sagt ganz klar wir sind dankbar für jede
hilfe es gibt aber auch ärzte
gewerkschafter die sagen wir müssen das
problem eigentlich jetzt erst mal im
eigenen land lösen und das halten wir
auch für möglich denn wie gesagt es gibt
große privatkliniken gerade in den
ballungsräumen die bisher noch nicht
durch große beteiligung an dem problem
aufgefallen waren
und da gab es ärztegewerkschaft hat die
gesagt haben die notstandsgesetzgebung
die höher seit letztem jahr haben die
gibt es hier diese krankenhäuser in die
pflicht zu nehmen
man müsste nur mal den politischen mut
aufbringen das auch durchzusetzen
einzufordern und letzten endes auch
durchzusetzen und
da war die regierung sehr sehr zögerlich
und es scheint sich jetzt doch eine
einvernehmliche lösung anzubahnen
dahingehend dass man verträge mit denen
schließt und das jetzt also in der
diskussion sind so bis zu 900 betten die
fed kranke aber auch für andere
intensivpflegebedürftige patienten
geöffnet werden um eben den öffentlichen
bereich zu entlasten und davon
verspricht man sich schon mal einiges
das ist eine sache die sich die
krankenhäuser natürlich jetzt auch mit
also die privaten kliniken natürlich
jetzt bezahlen lassen da hat sich auch
wieder ein bisschen unmut geregt aber es
ist immerhin eine einvernehmliche lösung
und ich denke in portugal ist man jetzt
geneigt erstmal abzuwarten was das
bringt patienten auszufliegen sagen
viele ärzte ist keine besonders gute
idee weil wenn es denen wirklich
schlecht geht dann ist ein transport
eigentlich gar nicht angezeigt deswegen
eben dieses ganz starke theorie für die
lösung im eigenen land und in spanien
wird es sehr sehr ähnlich gesehen wobei
der druck im moment nicht im ansatz so
groß ist wie in portugal auf dieses jahr
in ländern in denen das öffentliche
gesundheitswesen nicht besonders gut
entwickelt es sich nehme an dass sie da
portugal auch meinen entwickelt sich ja
immer so ein privater sektor dass die
wohlhabenden man sich eben privat
versorgen können hat er die politik in
portugal nicht die möglichkeit auch mit
gesetzgeberischen maßnahmen einzugreifen
und die mehr oder minder zu zwingen sich
an der an den gesundungsprozess eine
bekämpfung zu beteiligen
das ist ja wäre ja eine möglichkeit
portugal hat ja auch eine gewisse
verpflichtungen gegenüber den
europäischen staaten sie haben ja im
moment den ratsvorsitz in der
europäischen union auf den sie sich im
moment nicht so wirklich konzentrieren
können aber wie gesagt ja also die ärzte
des öffentlichen systems die
organisierten sagen die instrumente sind
da ja man könnte die man könnte die
privatkliniken zwingen nur wie gesagt
die regierung scheut davor zurück sie
sucht jetzt eben einvernehmliche
lösungen und da ist man ja auf dem weg
und und guckt jetzt erst mal wie das wie
das weitergehen wird
zumal die zahlen der letzten tagen eine
leichte besserung zeigen es könnte also
sein dass der druck so ein bisschen raus
geht
ich würde auch gerne noch mal eine lanze
für das öffentliche gesundheitssystem in
beiden
ländern brechen also so schlecht ist es
nicht
also als versicherte hier in spanien im
moment erlebe ich eigentlich dass man
sich sehr gut und auch sehr gut
präventiv um menschen kümmert aber was
in spanien im vergangenen frühjahr
passiert ist und was in portugal jetzt
passiert also das gesundheitssystem was
mit mit diesem mit dieser riesenwelle
mit diesem tsunami klar kommt das möchte
ich mal sehen also das ist auch ein
bisschen schwierig da jetzt
grundsätzlich falsche reaktionen
vorzuwerfen
und wie gesagt in portugals könnte sein
dass jetzt eben die die freiwillige
kooperation der privatkliniken die neuen
verträge
das diene erleichterung bringen vorteils
ihr habt das von in einem nebensatz
schon angedeutet stichwort priorisierung
das ja in deutschland auch ein wichtiges
thema beim impfen wer soll als erstes
geimpft werden die so genannten
variablen also besonders verletzlichen
gruppen vor allem die älteren menschen
und die die mit ihnen viel kontakt haben
also das pflegepersonal gibt es dann
verschiedene abstufungen jetzt gibt es
diskussionen weil ein impfstoff wie
astrazeneca an die alten gar nicht
eltern gar nicht mehr verimpft werden
soll jedenfalls sich in deutschland dann
in die diskussion jetzt von neuem los
wie ist das denn in südafrika zum
beispiel wird das da ähnlich gesehen
oder gibt es da andere priorisierungen
die die politik möglicherweise
gezwungenermaßen sogar vornehmen muss
also was man bei uns in südafrika sieht
und dass es definitiv auch an einen ein
ergebnis der erfahrungen die man hier
gemacht hat ist dass man sagt die ersten
die bei uns gibt werden dass sie die
mitarbeiter aus dem gesundheitswesen wir
haben allein im vergangenen jahr haben
sich 41.000 also mehr als 41.000
mitarbeiter aus dem gesundheitswesen
das geht über ärzte schwestern
krankenpflege aber eben auch
labormitarbeiter infiziert ankurbelt und
hunderte von ihnen sind gestorben
das heißt im moment sagt man die erste
priorität sind für uns die mitarbeiter
aus dem gesundheitswesen in der zweiten
phase geht man dann an wichtige
berufsgruppen wie beispielsweise
polizisten und aber auch risikogruppen
und ältere menschen und die dritte und
letzte phase das ist dann sozusagen der
rest der bevölkerung
also das ist im moment die priorisierung
die wir hier sehen aber bis das ich
wirklich was bewegt wird es eine ganze
weile noch
man denke ich ist es in den asiatischen
ländern gibt es da eine andere
herangehensweise dann sagt man muss
eigentlich erstmal die impfen und
schützen die die anderen schützen und
auch impfen sollen wie läuft es da eine
einheitliche sichtweise und eine
einheitliche vorgehensweise
ja ich glaub ich möchte einmal vorweg
schieben dass asien irgendwie so der
größte kontinent ist auch
bevölkerungsreichster es ist eine
unfassbar diverse länder und hier auch
sehr unterschiedliche strategien
eine interessante ist zum beispiel
indonesien die fangen nicht mit den
älteren leuten an sondern mit den
jüngeren menschen tatsächlich weil die
jüngeren menschen das
infektionsgeschehen maßgeblich antreiben
und in dem fall aber auch die
konstellation ein bisschen anders ist
also sie haben einfach eine relativ
junge bevölkerung die älteren sind nicht
so massenhaft in heimen zum beispiel so
wie bei uns was ja besonders gefährliche
orte dann sind und die jüngeren arbeiten
öfter dichter enger zusammen zum
beispiel großen fabriken und das sind
quasi deren super spredder orte
deswegen gehen die da zuerst vor
ansonsten bei den meisten anderen
asiatischen staaten gleiche strategie
unseren erst gesundheitswesen und dann
die eltern und risikogruppen und nach
und nach die anderen im vereinigten
königreich muss man sich da über
priorisierung nicht so viele gedanken
machen weil es sowieso genügend
impfstoff da ist oder ist das auch eine
diskussion
das ist schon lange da wird schon
priorisiert also man fängt auch mit der
älteren generation natürlich an und mit
demenz es also von dem gesundheitswesen
dem personal und sonst auch also zum
beispiel ich habe man ein kollege von
mir der der leidet an krone und deshalb
ist er ist ein immunsystem sehr
geschwächt er wurde auch karte schon
geben obwohl er erst 40 ist also sie da
wird schon genau geschaut wer ist
eigentlich am verletzten oder wer es
braucht es zuerst und sie die
großbritannien hat ja auch eine
interessante und auch kontroverse
strategie dass sie erst mal die erste
dosis an so viele menschen wie möglich
in nomine und menschen verabreichen und
dann sehr lange warten bis zur zweiten
dosis zu versuchen erstmal die erste
dosis in so viele arme wie möglich
reinen zu jagen wenn man das so salopp
sagen kann
und der gedanke dahinter ist dass mit
der ersten dosis die leute schon 70
ungefähr 70 75 prozent geschützt sind
und dass man deshalb eben warten kann
das ist aber nicht
so das ist eben kontrovers ob das
wirklich so stimmt aber so ist im moment
die strategie der regierung aber
brauchen wir angesichts der bedrohung
gerade in portugal wie geht man da denn
vor es gibt ja in großbritannien
sozusagen die die methode erst einmal zu
impfen um möglichst viel zu verändern
und dann zu sagen also so schnell wie
dies ist die zweite im vielleicht gar
nicht nötig da gibt es ja auch
diskussionen darüber wie geht man gerade
in solchen ländern die durch coop 19 so
bedroht sind mit dieser frage um
es ist tatsächlich so es gibt auf der
ganzen iberischen halbinsel sowohl in
spanien als auch in portugal
überlegungen durch eine durch eine
streckung der der zweite impfung
tatsächlich die die dosis zu vergrößern
und was die vorgehensweise anbelangt
liegt in beiden ländern die priorität
ganz klar zunächst mal auf älteren
bürgern und vor allen dingen auf
altenheimen weil man ja auch gerade in
spanien fürchterliche erfahrungen
gemacht hat im vergangenen frühjahr sind
wirklich zehntausende von menschen in
altenheimen gestorben und es ist also
nicht umsonst die erste patientin hier
einen im altenheim gewesen die auch dort
geimpft wurde vor ort und die zweite
person war eine pflegerin um eben zu
signalisieren und das ist in portugal
die anders wir versuchen erst mal die
leute zu schützen
bei denen es am dringendsten ist und wo
es am schlimmsten war in der in der
hochphase der der der epidemie ansonsten
wie gesagt streckung ist in der debatte
und ich glaube aber so weit wie in
deutschland das ist jetzt wirklich auch
praktiziert das ist man noch nicht
gelingen
ja es soll ja der impfstoff möglichst
gerecht verteilt werden
auf der welt das ist klar jeder möchte
das so bald wie möglich dran kommen
jedenfalls von denen die geimpft werden
wollen
trotzdem gibt es den vorwurf des
internationalismus im zusammenhang mit
dem streit der europäischen union mit
dem vereinigten königreich wo wohnen
denn die schlimmsten internationalisten
die insel oder auf dem kontinent ja also
ich muss sagen da finde ich hab die eu
sich nicht so gut verhalten nicht das
war das ist haben sie auch dann
zurückgenommen und sich eigentlich auch
dafür entschuldigt aber dann diese
einfach damit zu drohen dass das dass
die ausfuhr nach nordirland gestoppt
werden das war das war keine gute idee
und das hätte hätte man nicht machen
sollen und es wurde ja da auch nicht
gemacht also aber natürlich alle haben
angst und alle wollen so viel impfstoff
wie möglich für irland bekommen nur hat
großbritannien einfach besser früher
verhandelt die schneller die verträge
abgeschlossen und da hat daher mehr
impfstoff im land das stimmt schon die
eu hat viel zu lange sich dann mit den
verträgen beschäftigt und mit der leitet
also mit dem wir dann zuständig ist
man hätte da einfach schnell viel
einkaufen müssen also die volksseele
kocht glaube ich auf der insel ganz
besonders der eigentlich katalysator der
das auch besonders zeigt sie ist die
irgendwo auf der welt so stark
entwickelt wie bei ihnen nämlich die
boulevardpresse da ist bekommt also eu
er bekommt unseren impfstoff nicht ist
dass er so ein bisschen heißer gekocht
als das dann gegessen wird oder bahnt
sich da wirklich ein konflikt an der
möglicherweise sogar in einen
handelskrieg
münden könnte ich hoffe nicht ich glaube
man muss das alles noch im kontext von
brt exit sehen nicht das ist diese die
jetzt dass es sehr stark das nationale
gefühl und jetzt will großbritannien
auch zeigen dass sie eben alleine ohne
die eu die sache viel besser machen
können und das haben er für viele diese
episode bewiesen nicht sagen ja seht ihr
wir haben das jetzt eben schon gerade
mit dem impfstoff besser gemacht als sie
die als die langsame eu und wir sind
eben schneller und wendiger wir alleine
als vereinigtes königreich und man muss
natürlich zu geben in diesem spitz in
dieser speziellen frage war das auch so
aber gut beim impfstoff ist es
vielleicht zu sagen ja speziellen frage
beim lebensmittelhandel oder versorgung
oder beim fischfang möglicherweise nicht
merken die briten da jetzt dass der
projekte möglicherweise doch auch
nachteile hat alles überlagert durch ja
natürlich merken das schon schon
unternehmen die merken dass die
einfuhren teurer werden die merken dass
da sehr viel mehr bürokratie ist das war
jetzt nicht der ganz grosse knall oder
die größte katastrophe so es am anfang
des jahres waren ist ja ihr habt ihr
nicht stattgefunden aber das wird
langsam gehen und das wird auch lange
dauern und und da würde jeder im land
wahrscheinlich merken dass
wirtschaftlich praxis von großem
nachteil für großbritannien auch von
nachteil zu nachteilen für die eu ist
aber doch im vergleich zu einem viel
größeren nachteil für die briten sein
wird also viele probleme viele länder
viele unterschiedliche probleme auch
manche gemeinsamkeiten das war mal einen
blick
rund um den fast rund um den globus in
sachen kroner pandemie ich bedanke mich
bei vanessa ruhe und weil wenn konkrete
hier im studio bei landrat eis aus
johannesburg und bei natalie bachmeier
ausmasse vielen dank dass sie da waren
die wir zuschauer auch am montag bei
unter den linden beschäftigen wir uns
mit corona mit dem thema corona und
gerechtigkeit gast bei michaela kolster
sind dann norbert walter borjans der
spd-parteivorsitzende und der
generalsekretär der fdp volker wissing
da ist sicherlich große politische
unterhaltung vorprogrammiert am montag
um 22 uhr 15
jetzt folgt für nicht der tag mit
michael krons darin unter anderem dass
phoenix trendbarometer und da geht es
natürlich auch um die haltung der
bevölkerung zur bekämpfung
von corona hier in deutschland bleiben
sie bei uns
[Musik]